revolution is coming it's said by
thousands of people who
exiled from cuba to come to little
havana in miami protesting going around
happy about the fact that potentially
cuba will be free again in a democracy
again but in order for that to become a
reality i got a few items i want to go
through with you one we need to know the
history of it
i got 14 points on why this protestant
is taking place
there are some interesting reasons there
but there's also one big leak
in this protesting why the revolution
may not happen
that the cuban folks ought to take a
page out of the iranian revolution
playbook so let me get right into a few
things
let's let's look at the history of
what's going on right now with 1933 i'm
not going to go far back
with christopher columbus i'm just going
to go to 1933. 1933
fdr helps cuba become a democracy from
1933 to 1952
everything is good until a military
leader has a coup
there is a coup and he takes over he's a
dictator
pushing people around telling everybody
how things ought to be
but that 1952 when that happens an idea
a concept of communism starts spreading
in cuba with this voice this figurehead
castro
that seems very uh attractive and and
the messaging
the rich are taken over batista is
simply a puppet for us
do you want cuba to be owned by u.s all
these conversations that are taking
place
so u.s has to align themselves between a
dictator
and a communist and they say well we
can't go here we have to align ourselves
with this because the cold war russia
all that stuff at the time they align
themselves with this
castro uses that 1959 he takes over
the place becomes a communistic regime
from 59 and 62 is the heat of the cuban
missile crisis kennedy's thinking about
attacking
generals are saying do it they see the
images of nuclear weapons
you know the cuba is thinking about who
to align themselves up with there is
this embargo
which is the highest level of sanctions
that u.s cannot do business with
cuba and any of their allies cannot do
business with cuba gets very ugly
long story short castro takes advantage
of this
and while the sanctions are given to
them with an embargo typically a couple
things happen when there's an embargo
when you have an embargo and you tell
sanctions like let's just say u.s gave
sanctions to iran
you can't do business with iran all this
other stuff right
but what iran does is wait a minute you
don't want to do any business with us no
iran either is going to experience a
revolution because if people revolt
or iran has to go and find another ally
iran goes and signs a 25-year contract
400 billion dollars
with who with china same thing happened
during that time where castro are saying
wait a minute
you don't want to be an ally even though
we're neighbors with you
no problem u.s guess who i'm going to go
be an ally with
in that time in the early 60s you know
who
ussr your number one enemy so whenever
you push back with embargo
that country has a choice either
revolution takes place which the people
takes a lot of work for that to become a
reality or that country has to go find
another person to align themselves up
with another country
to align themselves with and that's kind
of what happened during that time with
castro
next in 1980 jimmy carter is a president
and jimmy carter is going after two
countries one of them is
cuba the other one is iran and in cuba
it's okay it's not fair what you're
doing it's not for what's going on
so finally castro opens it up in 1980
sends 125 000 refugees
to miami and then closes it up again and
he send a lot of the political prisoners
a lot of people that he didn't like
he sent him up there so that's what
happens in 1980 during that time i think
miami had an unemployment rate of 50
the next 12 months it was a pretty rough
time during that specific period
but that's what happened next continues
clinton comes back
during his time he says listen this
embargo is no longer happening we should
put a stop to it
why are we still doing this castro ends
up shooting down two planes that were
against his regime then they said okay i
think we got to continue this embargo
so then in 2008 his brother raul castro
takes over
business as usual same philosophy fast
forward to barack obama becoming the
president
gradually starts talking about nothing's
really going on in cuba why are we so
upset with them today they're quiet
they're harmless why don't we lift the
embargo let's lift the sanctions he does
i think in 2015 and 2016 he goes there
for three days he becomes the first
president since like
calvin coolidge to go to cuba and he
watches the game
baseball game with raul castro
communists they're laughing
and the media lost their mind why is the
u.s president laughing and doing a
baseball game with the communists
and then that leads to 2018 miguel diaz
uh
canal takes over cuba after raul and
then 2020
2021 one of the last things president
trump did is he put the embargo
on the sanctions back on cuba and then
that's kind of where we are today so now
let's talk about the reasons why this is
taking place
in cuba today number one why they're
protesting
lack of freedom okay they want to be
free again coronavirus vaccine
regulation internet they don't have
access to the internet
there was a video that you see
circulating and going viral with a
mother
recording the sun that's not doing
anything cops come and take them there's
a lot of videos right now circulating
with a wife holding her kids screaming
with blood all over just a lot of
different footage that people are
sharing right now so the way to cut it
off is let's cut the internet so the
world cannot see how bad things are over
there
and it's not pretty what they're doing
the way they're pinning the people
against each other it's it's it's
non-stop inflation's obviously out of
control
i mean it's to the point where a bit of
the revolution got
the president to lift food medicine
customs restrictions after protest
because
if a doctor makes forty dollars a month
in cuba let me say this one more time a
doctor in cuba makes forty dollars a
month
but if you wanna buy ten tylenols it's
worth a hundred dollars how do you do
that how do you buy tylenol
so it's out of control with the cost
that they had there the president
obviously blamed u.s for the sanctions
and the embargo
and you know it's not our fault it's not
the fact that we're doing it people are
not protesting here because it's
cuba libra and it's not they don't want
liberty it's more because
it's us's fault right lots of problems
back to back to back to back to back
it's constant and here's a challenge
with
governments like cuba and iran if
publicly you protest against the
government
and the regime good luck with your
career
it's as if you if to give you the
analogy here it's like on your credit
score you know how they say in us when
you get a bankruptcy stays on your
credit for seven years
when you get a mark like this where you
protest against the regime
it stays on your credit with that regime
for the rest of your life so you're
better off not saying anything don't go
out there and protest
to the fact that people are protesting
one of our guys here said one of the
best things about why he believes the
protesting is taking place and that's
paul
he said it's because the people in cuba
are more educated they're getting
educated
they're understanding the concept of
freedom they want to be free and i fully
agree with them the fact that people are
sitting around saying
this is what i want to do i want to be
free why are we not fighting for freedom
why can't we be feel
free like other places and education can
do that this is why a lot of countries
are preventing
doing whatever they can to not allow
their people to get educated by not
giving them internet access
not giving them ability to see what else
is going around the world so now here's
the problem let me go back to the
problem
this is the problem that we're looking
at with this the protesting it's by the
people
and it's real and it's not something
that
uh is just a one day two-day thing but
they're missing one thing
there is no unifying voice none when
iran had happened
they had a unifying voice when it
happened other countries
they had a unifying voice there is
nobody behind them to rally behind
so what you want to do this who's going
to replace miguel diaz canel who
who do you have that's going to replace
him you need one voice
you need one person that's standing up
and people are saying i want to get
behind this person here and by the way
another one another thing here that i
want to throw in there for you to be
thinking about is the following
somehow elon musk gets into this
conversation you know elon musk's uh uh
star link that he's working on the
satellite that he wants to provide
internet for the world and you know hey
i want to make sure the world gets free
internet then the connection they have
is they have the satellite but you need
the machine that's 400
which is going to be still a little bit
complicated about how do you do it do
you drop some of those things into
cuba here's the thing long term do you
know
who doesn't you know how many nations
don't want their
people to have free access to the
internet many of them
because if they do and their people get
educated do you know what happens with
revolution
goes to a whole different level if
it gets to that point so um i
totally feel for the people of cuba i
experienced this as a kid when we
escaped iran at 10 years old and we came
to the states here
that's still my homeland that's where i
was born that's where i went to the
first school
i have memories of that place so i
understand how emotional it is
when i'm hearing the people of cuba with
their rally cries
and you know it's a real rally cry
because they personally experienced this
or their family's going through it right
now
so having said that it's going to be
very interesting to see what happens the
next few days
but i hope the cuban people figure out a
way to rally behind
one voice you need one voice to face off
against
miguel diaz canel and that way of
thinking
that one person needs to rise up and
hopefully it's a person that's a true
believer that's tough that's got the
courage to keep going because it's not
going to be easy
before they get democracy and freedom
there's going to be a lot more
manipulation taking place between now
and then
if you enjoy this video and you want to
find out why i keep talking about iran
and cuba i did a video a couple years
ago talking about the history of u.s
iran conflict if you've never watched it
this will give you a lot of insight
of what's going on today in cuba take
care everybody bye-bye
you